levez la main si vous savez ce que c'est
aurait dû penser que je ne peux pas le voir
si vous levez la main
il y a plusieurs centaines d'années bien avant votre
naissance cela a été inventé cela a simplement
une fonction et c'est de jouer de la musique
il y a  pas d'écran tactile il n'y a pas de
streaming écouter une cassette vous avez commencé
au début vous avez terminé à la fin
vous ne pouviez pas appuyer sur la lecture aléatoire ne pouvait pas
aller et venir vous ne pouviez pas appuyer sur répéter
vous écoutez une bande comme si vous étiez
assis à un  concert mais tout dans la facilité et le
confort d'une promenade alors ils ont appelé un
baladeur que
vous mettez sur la tête et vous pouvez vous promener
homme
j'espère que vous êtes prêt ce sera ici d'une
minute à l'autre qu'un fusil vous savez ce qu'est un
fusil de vue
c'est juste en quelque sorte votre truc et votre arme
pour le mien mais je suppose que nous faisons tous les deux des armes
maintenant je ne savais tout simplement pas que non c'est ça
je le vois en vous peur jalousie
trahison c'est notre signal pour nettoyer l'univers
de l'école
vous savez qu'ils  m'a dit que vous étiez des
connards vaniteux mais ce n'est pas le cas  rue
du tout
mec j'utilise mes mauvais yeux ne mets pas
ta ceinture de sécurité sur
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que sauver la galaxie à nouveau oui
nous allons vraiment pouvoir augmenter
nos prix pour la double galaxie Davis
[Musique]
ça alors
salut
[Musique]
parfois la chose que tu cherches
toute ta vie
c'est juste là à tes côtés à ta
droite
tout ce que tu fais avec Jana
pas de famille
[Musique]
alors peut-être qu'elle
après toutes ces années je '  Je t'ai trouvé et
qui diable es-tu Je suis ton père Peter
toi